Oh okay yeah sure fine uh hello I'm the Batman and
I mean I'm like hello I'm Bruce Wayne who's Bruce
Wayne with great power comes Square responsibility
are you doing Batman where are you sure Tom if
you keep doing this we're gonna get sued I have
so much money I'm Batman no you're not Batman.
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
full breakdown Easter eggs video for the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special there's a whole
bunch of references so we'll break it all down
whole bunch of Cameo scenes too like there was
even a stealth Mark Hamill Cameo scene that some
of you may have spotted if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll be doing a bunch of Guardians of the Galaxy
3 videos soon and we have Ant-Man and the Wasp
Quantumania coming we're gonna get another trailer
for that really soon as well careful for spoilers
from the entire special if you haven't seen it yet
but there's no special subtitle it's just called
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special it's meant
to be Marvel's version of the Star Wars holiday
special from 1978 the title is kind of the same
the font is a little bit the same Marvel's whole
thing with the special presentations are based
on the original CBS special presentations which
is what the Star Wars holiday special was also the
Mark Hamill Cameo scene at the end of the special
like you see him as one of the ravagers during
the big celebration Montage that's meant to be
another reference to the Star Wars holiday special
because he played Luke Skywalker during that they
did have a new Marvel Studios intro themed for
Christmas for the holidays and normally when you
have all the comic book pages flipping through
the beginning of the logo as it transitions to
the different scenes usually all the comics are
based on whichever characters the movie is about
like the Guardians of the Galaxy comic book pages
during their movies but this time because it's a
holiday special like a Christmas special all
the pages are from the Marvel holiday special
Comics that's why you see Santa Claus in some of
these images because Santa Claus is a mutant in
the MCU he's an Omega Level mutant one of the most
powerful ones there are the Marvel holiday special
Comics have been a thing going on since 1991.
they've done special event Comics way back to the
beginning of Marvel Comics but the actual holiday
specials didn't start till 1991 and in number one
is when they canonize Santa as a mutant in the
MCU the other brand new thing that you probably
spotted in the intro are She-Hulk scenes and shuri
black panther scenes from the end of that movie
because this is literally coming out right after
black panther wakanda forever came out and they
usually updated every single time a brand new
Marvel movie or marble Disney plus series comes
out the song that's playing over this opening
title is one of the original songs that James
Gunn did with the old 97s band who themselves
were playing aliens living on nowhere with the
Guardians of the Galaxy here they did two original
songs for this and one of them was sung by Kevin
Bacon at the end because Kevin Bacon is a musician
in real life in addition to being an actor if he
didn't know he has a band with his brothers called
The Brothers bacon and they've released six albums
so far a lot of the lyrics of both of the original
songs are meant to highlight the action of the
actual episode like not totally understanding
what Christmas is the Guardians of the Galaxy the
other people on nowhere not really knowing what
Christmas is having all these misconceptions about
Santa Claus the funny thing about that Old 97 song
about Santa Claus being this terrible person the
L is plotting his demise is that in the Marvel
holiday special Comics Santa actually wore The
Infinity Gauntlet once and fought the Illuminati
the basic premise of the episode is that mantis
wants to cheer Peter Quill up by throwing him a
Christmas that he'll really enjoy James can set
up to this point she's been a relatively minor
character and he wanted to show her off more
like become a much bigger part of the team than
she seemed like in the past the actual opening
scene is an animated flashback of Kraglin telling
the story of the first Christmas that Peter Quill
tried to throw and teach him and yondu about it in
yondu being this super big Grinch the actual style
of the animation looks very similar to The Heavy
Metal animated movie from the 80s too but it's
basically them celebrating that first Christmas
on the eclectorship and obviously you find out the
rest of the story at the end but the whole joke
here at the beginning is that they think that
it was a rotten Christmas because Kraglin never
heard the rest of the story and they only know
about Christmas after hearing Kraglin and talk
about it I believe Peter Quill is meant to be like
12 13 years old during this like he's still really
really young but he's been with the ravagers for a
little while at this point Michael Rooker did come
back to play his character so it's like brand new
Michael Rooker stuff but it is a flashback the
ship that they're on to the eclector it's part
of the larger ravagers home-base ship, they blew
up part of it during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 but
this part of the ship will be back in Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 all the decorations on the tree
there are just random electrical parts that he
found across the ship when yondu references the
fires of ogard that's a reference to Starhawk
Sylvester Stallone's character from Guardians 2
his real name is takar ogard he was the leader of
the Guardians 3000 the original Guardians of the
Galaxy team in the Marvel Comics in the MCU the
whole story is that that was yondu's original team
because in the comics way back in the day yandu
was on that very first Guardians of the Galaxy
3000 comic book team but the whole idea here is
that Peter Quill is giving him one of those little
toys that he keeps around on the collector into
present day like you see little toys that yondu
has like the troll doll during the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie all those are meant to be
little things that Peter Quill has given to him
across the years there are several of them meaning
that they had several Christmas celebrations like
this across the years the joke about cleaning the
latrines being Jeff's favorite job is a Steven A G
joke he's the one that plays Jeff during Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 this character here he shows up
in most of James Gunn's projects like he was just
in Peacemaker too there were actually a lot of
actors from The Suicide Squad movie in Peacemaker
which James Gunn both made so a lot of James Gunn
recurring actors showed up as cameos during this
the plays that they're on right now is nowhere
they explained during the special that they bought
it from The Collector meaning that the collector
would have had to survive Avengers Infinity War
for them to buy it from him in the first place so
that's actually pretty big reveal that he's still
alive we all thought that he died during Infinity
War the multi-calendor that cragland mentions just
contains important dates from cultures all across
the universe so I could have important as guardian
dates important dates from Earth important dates
from all over the place some of the street signs
that you see down on the street there like there's
a neon rat sign those were featured during the
first two Guardians of the Galaxy movies they
reintroduced Cosmo the talking dog because we
saw her during the first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie Her full name from the comics is Cosmo
the talking dog she's based on Laika the Russian
space dock from the 1950s the difference with the
MCU origin story is the cosmo was fired into space
bombarded with cosmic rays and wound up on nowhere
and that's how she wound up in the collector's
collection the reason James Gunn and said that
she wasn't a bigger character in the previous
Guardians of the Galaxy movies is just because
he already had the talking raccoon the talking
tree and he felt like At the beginning when he was
first starting the franchise putting a talking dog
on top of that throughout the entire movie would
have just been too much too soon she's voiced by
Maria bakalova and the reason why she's wearing
the Soviet Union space uniform is because that
was when she was fired into space when the Soviet
Union still existed and that's why when you hear
her telepathic thoughts her voice sounds like it's
Russian because she grew up in Russia so she has
a Russian accent in the comics Cosmo is a male dog
the reason why it's a girl in the MCU is because
James Gunn wanted to be truer to the source
material and because Cosmo is based on Laika the
real life Russian space dog in real life Laika
was a female dog they give you a little tutorial
on how her powers work she uses telekinesis she
has telepathy to talk so she kind of beams her
thoughts into your head she doesn't move her lips
and as the Old 97 sings The Christmas Song they
play opening credits which Marvel usually doesn't
do most of their credits come at the end of their
movies the actual lettering is also Christmas
themed as well they reintroduced the bigger now
teenage version of Groot who's grown much larger
thick Groot Chad version of Groot however you
want to think of him this is mostly to get him
ready for Guardians of the Galaxy 3 where I think
he'll eventually grow back to regular full-size
Drax and mantis come up with their idea to cheer
Peter Quill up by throwing the celebration for him
and yoinking the legendary Kevin Bacon who they
think is this Grand hero leader of all earth like
Drax actually thinks that he is the leader of the
entire planet the other joke here too is that Drax
says that he hates stories where everyone lives
and this story is one of the few Guardians of
the Galaxy stories where no one actually dies
they also make a lot of meta jokes about hating
actors like oh actors so terrible I hate them
and Manchester tries to throw up just at the
thought of an actor when they're all literally
actors playing characters in this production so
they're kind of clowning on themselves in a meta
way the reason why they thought of Kevin Bacon is
because Peter Quill believes that Footloose
is the greatest movie of all time and won't
shut up about it you remember that he left Earth
in 1988 so all of his knowledge of pop culture
and movies everything is just Frozen in the 80s
so I believe the last Kevin Bacon movie that he
might have seen would have been Planes Trains
and Automobiles which is also a Thanksgiving
movie like this was released during Thanksgiving
they introduced Kevin Bacon who's playing himself
the actor inside the MCU all kinds of jokes about
the weird continuity issues because he played a
version of Sebastian Shaw in the fox Marvel X-Men
movies it's kind of like Samuel L Jackson playing
Nick Fury but also being Mace Windu in the Star
Wars movies which are Canon to the MCU the Kira
that he talks to on the phone is his wife in real
life Kira Sedgwick that is her voice on the phone
so she did have a small Cameo scene Dragon mantis
take off of nowhere we get a really cool shot
of it we haven't actually seen nowhere in a MCU
production since the first Guardians of the Galaxy
film the brand new [__] that they're on the
brand new guardianship is called the Bowie after
David Bowie because all their ships are named
after 70s and 80s pop stars the first one was
the Milano after Alyssa Milano the second one was
the Benetar after Pat Benatar and now David Bowie
it actually looks pretty cool I actually like this
ship the best because of the eternals movie we've
been going deeper into celestial's lore in the MCU
so nowhere is the head of a dead Celestial in the
comics it was null that killed that Celestial it
was originally the green one that you saw in the
eternals movie Jamaya the analyzer in the MCU they
could say that Galactus was the person who killed
this Celestial when they arrived in Los Angeles on
planet Earth the whole joke everybody freaking out
is that they think there's another Alien Invasion
remember this is meant to be Christmas 2025 and
this is taking place so the Earth has already been
through several invasions they already know about
the stone Celestial inside the Indian Ocean so
everyone's freaking out like oh no not another
Alien Invasion like another Thanos character has
come back to take over this is the real Hollywood
Boulevard in Los Angeles that they filmed in at
man's Chinese Theater this area is also Rife with
cosplayers that do a lot of Marvel characters that
you can pay to take pictures with which they use
for a lot of Comedy during this particular scene
the accurate ad in the background seems like it's
a depiction of wakandans even Black Panther on
it part of the joke here too is that the other
regular humans think that they're also cosplayers
and pay them a bunch of money we see versions of
Captain America Iron Man Spider-Man Ant-Man
Black Widow Captain Marvel the other Avengers
that they've known in real life they have a joke
about that too mantis thinking that it's the real
Captain America I also love the idea that she
hates Captain Marvel for some reason like she
can't stand Captain Marvel she would have only met
her for like a couple minutes during Avengers end
game they have references to Zorro Jack Sparrow
from Pirates of the Caribbean this is a really
funny Gobot reference their 80s rip-offs of
Transformers I remember watching that television
show and having some of those Gobot toys Peter
Quill would know about the GoBots because they
were around during the early 80s and apparently
Drax thinks a Gobot killed his cousin which they
pay off later when he beats the hell out of that
Gobot cosplayer R.I.P to that guy the mom here
that thinks that he's cosplaying Kratos God of War
is actually James Gunn's real life sister-in-law
she's been in a bunch of his Productions as well
so there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs going
on in this scene they actually just released the
latest God of War Game there's a real quick blink
on you'll miss it reference to one of kingo's
recent Christmas movies that he made before the
eternals were joint by ayersham the judge at the
end of that movie remember he got yanked off a
planet meaning that he would have made this movie
before that happened and they're just releasing it
now because the events of the eternals movie take
place way before the events of this the bar that
they go to yarvos is a reference to James Gunn's
friend in real life David yaraveski who goes by
the nickname yarvo he directed breitburn which
James Gunn also produced and if he didn't realize
the music they're playing in the bar the Blondie
is 70s 80s music because all the music from the
Guardians movies is from the 70s they're kind
of creeping into the 80s now in terms of mixtape
music but the bartender you probably recognized
as flu laborg who was also in The Suicide Squad
movie The Other Easter egg here is that in the
Suicide Squad movie Palm clementiev who plays
mantis also cameo'd is one of the dancing girls
at the bars they visit during that film they use
the star our Maps which are also a real thing you
can actually buy to find Kevin Bacon's house like
you can go on tours in the Hollywood Hills of
stars houses this person is Rusty Schwimmer you
probably recognize from some TV show she's been in
a billion different things she uses her power to
steal the money in the map that also foreshadows
her using her powers on Kevin Bacon then on the
actual map they have all kinds of Easter eggs and
references here so they have John Cena and Margot
Robbie's house because of the Suicide Squad movie
Harley Quinn Peacemaker which James Gunn directed
one of the other jokes here is that a lot of
these other people were all big stars during the
80s because Peter Quill left Earth in the 80s he'd
remember them he'd have seen movies and TV shows
with them in it like apparently he watched Saved
by the Bell knew about that so he knew about Mark
Paul Gossler playing a version of Zach Morris he
also knew about Arnold Schwarzenegger because of
his 80s movies the last Schwarzenegger movie he
probably saw was the twins movie and also if it
wasn't obvious these aren't the actual locations
of where these celebrities live like they're just
random locations around the Los Angeles area like
the house that they go to isn't Kevin Bacon's
house in real life when they go to Kevin Bacon's
house the Christmas movie that's playing on the TV
is Santa Claus Conquers the Martians which is
an old 60s movie reference to Drax and mantis
invading Earth so to speak stealing Kevin Bacon
there's also a joke line here that he listens to
about never coming back to Earth because there's
a bit of a joke at the end of the special like
maybe Kevin Bacon won't come back to earth even
though they do wind up bringing him back when they
start chasing Kevin Bacon down they also use the
scene to show you some of their powers in the way
they haven't done before like they do have super
strength mantis can also move a little bit like
Spider-Man when the police show up to help him
this actress is also from The Suicide Squad movie
this upside down caught that Drax almost killed
is also real life Barry Curtis who's Marvel's
real life head of security he had similar types of
cameos and a bunch of other Marvel movies playing
in Universe security guards and cops because
that's basically what he does for Marvel in real
life like anytime there's a big leak or somebody
steals something from Marvel orders like some big
legal problem he usually gets involved with that
the Christmas store signage is also meant to be
the same font is the the opening titles which is
where they get all the decorations from that they
put up later on nowhere we find out that mantis
knows all about fawns from happy days because
Peter Quill would have watched reruns of that show
and he's talked to them about all the pop culture
bands and TV shows and movies that he liked they
have a big conversation about the Footloose movie
obviously because of the big reference during
Avengers Infinity War they talked to him about
the dance off to save the universe because of
the end of the Footloose movie they have the big
dance off also like I said Peter Quill thinks that
Footloose is the greatest movie of all time they
referenced the Friday the 13th movie the first
one which Kevin Bacon was in if you forgot he also
jokes about not actually killing Jason like he
didn't actually die in the first movie they make
all the actor jokes like actors suck Kevin Bacon
you suck pretend like you don't suck he pretends
to be a British soldier with a British accent
from World War II he makes a Batman reference
so Batman is now Canon to the MCU I think this is
the first time they've actually referenced Batman
in the MCU the Kevin Bacon Batman joke is also
a super deep cut reference to Jim Carrey joke
from back in the day on The Tonight Show when
he did an impression of Kevin Bacon as Batman
I don't think that Kevin Bacon ever auditioned for
any of the older Batman movies in real life but if
you think he did write in the comments below love
that they surprised Peter with him gift wrapped
inside a box like a present then after Kraglin
tells him about the dance-off to save the universe
the Footloose stands off to save the universe
he comes around and sings the original song
they wrote with the old 97s because like I said
he's a performer in real life like he's an actual
musician so he can actually sing the joke of
Adam getting the cell phone reception all the way
across the Galaxy is just that their Tech allows
them to receive signals from across the universe
which they referenced during Thor love and thunder
like oh we're getting signals from all over the
universe as they begin exchanging Christmas
gifts he gives Groot an original game boy this
is original Hardware because Groot likes video
games he plays handheld games the last one we
saw him playing during Avengers Infinity war was a
portable version of Defender which was an original
arcade game from 1981. you can let me know in
the comments which games you think Groot is
going to be playing on this first then big WTF has
Christmas gift nebula actually gets rocket Winter
Soldiers vibranium arm and this is the current one
that was given to him during Avengers Infinity War
paying off the infinity War Easter egg I'm gonna
get that arm and he did get that arm so now you're
wondering is there like a winter soldier running
around on Earth that's armless how's he gonna
get that back and this is taking place after the
events of Falcon and Winter Soldier we know Bucky
is going to be back during the Thunderbolts movie
probably Captain America 4 as well because Peter
Quill was so quick to want to return Kevin Bacon
to Earth he probably did the same thing eventually
with winter soldier's arm like dude we got to
take this back to Winter Soldier you just have
to imagine nebula showing up and Wrecking him
like I'm taking that arm one way or the other
Cosmo brings a dead animal for Kraglin which is
a joke about your pets in real life like cats and
dogs bringing you dead animals and just leaving
them lying around the driveway or the house
mantis gives Drax the elf that he thought that
he had lost and groot's present to everyone are
little wooden dioramas depicting the events of the
holiday special built from pieces of himself like
all this wood is from Groot the way the storm
Breakers handle is from Groot it starts at the
beginning of them on the balcony than them chasing
Kevin Bacon on Earth Drax almost killing the
police revealing Kevin Bacon in the giant gift box
and the last one is a diorama of kraglan holding
a diorama of himself holding an even smaller
diorama of himself like it's a model of a model
of a model because Groot grew this you wonder how
small he could actually go like how many versions
of cragland holding this in the scene here he
would have had to have made this like literally
right on the spot you may remember a couple years
ago when James Gunn was still riding Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 he had this big meeting with Mark
Hamill so we all theorized that he would be in
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 obviously it's been a
long time since then a bunch of stuff happened
he might still be in Guardians of the Galaxy 3 but
their meeting could have just led to this holiday
special Cameo scene the other big surprise is that
Kevin Bacon implies that he's going to visit them
on Easter of next year during another holiday
so to speak and I think that's meant to flow
with the whole idea of the post-credits scene that
there will be another holiday special there will
be more specials Peter quilt reveals the rest
the story from that first Christmas with yondu
the taser face reference because he was a ravager
for a long time before he rebelled yondu's Grinch
heart melting and giving a gift to Peter Quill as
well giving him the two blasters the gift that was
given to yondu as I said earlier is one of the
little toys that you see in present day like he
gave him many different gifts across the years
the troll doll during the first Guardians of the
Galaxy movie is another example that from a later
Christmas and when they take off at the end of the
episode they sit down the ship. they're on is the
same eclector ship from Guardians of the Galaxy 2.
Mantis tells Peter Quill the truth about being his
half-sister from ego The Living Planet I love the
way she tells him too he's my father too so like
the wheels start turning in his head like wait a
minute you're my sister they actually revealed
this back during Guardians of the Galaxy 2 but
I think it just got lost in the shovel because
it was so much of an info dump with a bunch of
stuff going on in that movie like I believe in
the big Montage of him getting it on with the
entire universe here in the background you see
a member of mantis's race that's meant to be her
mother and she wasn't born with the same type of
ability that he was looking for that Peter Quill
had so that he could take over over the universe
but she did have a special ability that was useful
to him which is why he didn't kill her like the
other children then in the actual post-credits
scene they have rocket and Cosmo dressed and
grewed up like a Christmas tree because he is
a talking tree which he gets tired of and they
claim that he's ruined Christmas again and now
they have to do a whole other special which
is just a larger reference to them doing more
holiday specials in the future I already talked
about the Deadpool Christmas special I'll post a
link for that at the end of this and down in the
description below the other big thing here too is
that rocket was breaking the fourth wall which is
pretty rare in the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
but they've done it before in the MCU a couple
times obviously Deadpool will do it as well when
he comes to the MCU then I believe within the next
couple of months inside the MCU like looking in
real time into early 2026 that's when the events
of Ant-Man and the Wasp Quantumania take place
in Guardians of the Galaxy 3. I believe they're
both meant to take place around the same time
Ant-Man and the Wasp quantumania is also meant
to be the very first Marvel Phase 5 movie like
the beginning of Marvel phase 5. we'll get a new
trailer for that in a new Guardians of the Galaxy
3 trailer really soon of course I'll do a bunch of
videos for all that stuff be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my Deadpool Christmas special
video and click here for that new Spider-Man
and Daredevil clip with them going up against
Kingpin thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!